tout le discours de manuel valls repose
sur un mensonge qui consiste à dire si
on met à bas le code du travail on va on
va embaucher davantage on va créer des
emplois
or il faudra il a dit qu'il fallait
qu'il devrait convaincre mais il a
intérêt à affûter ses arguments
parce que faudra nous expliquer comment
par exemple parce que ça fait partie du
projet de loi en faisant voler en éclats
tous qui encadre le temps de travail
donc en faisant travailler davantage
ceux qui ont un emploi puisqu'on va on
va permettre dans le projet de loi
d'aller jusqu'à quarante six heures par
semaine pendant 16 semaines consécutives
est ce qu'avec ça on va créer des
emplois alors qu'il ya déjà 5 millions
de chômeurs dans le pays
et beaucoup de jeunes qui sont en
formation et qui vont entrer sur le
marché du travail va vous ne le
souhaitez pas que c'était pas qu'il
aille jusqu'au bout mais concrètement
vous et est ce que vous appelez à la
riposte et sous quelle forme
j'appelle effectivement j'ai j'ai moi
même signé un appel qui fait partie des
appels qui circule sur internet
j'appelle d'ores et déjà de toute façon
à la mobilisation sous toutes ses formes
est déjà une bataille d'explication
parce qu'il faut démontrer les mensonges
qui sont derrière le 10 mais abhorré des
syndicats vous espérez un front uni des
syndicats on n'a pas vu ça depuis
longtemps bien sûr que je l'espère parce
que là on a besoin d'unité et ce qui est
frappant depuis la publication de
l'avant projet de loi c'est l'ampleur de
la protestation en quelques jours des
pétitions en ligne qui sont couvertes de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
signatures et des réactions d'hostilité
ou de mécontentement qui balaye très
très très large
au point que les seules encouragements
que j'ai entendu ces derniers jours
viennent uniquement deux du medef du
medef et de certains secteurs de la
droite puisque eric woerth a dit qu' il
aurait pu écrire le projet de loi manuel
valls rétorqué l'autre jour en alsace et
et hier d'ailleurs et que c'est en
renvoyant ses détracteurs 19e siècle
santé mais la surveillance ou de la
charité l'hôpital qui se fout de la
charité mais parce que précisément si on
appliquait si vous votez par malheur le
projet de loi n conneries alors là c'est
un retour sur tout ce qui a été
construit au fil de décennies pour
organiser une protection collective des
salariés devant les risques de la
précarité et du chômage
est ce que vous voyez avec ce texte qui
portait donc par la mairieà belle
connerie
est ce que vous voyez naître une
nouvelle fracture politique dans ce pays
qui va bien au delà celle des frondeurs
par exemple et la fracture à les
consommer la fracture entre ses tics
cette petite équipe gouvernementale qui
a fait sortir petit à petit tous les
ministres mais là il y en a d'autres qui
jouent également là qui on a parlé d'un
élargissement ou non mais ça n'est pas
un élargissement c'est un gouvernement
qui n'a fait depuis son camp qu'une
seule chose c'est se rétrécir petit à
petit et qui a dû sortir de ce
gouvernement tout ce qui m était une
voix un peu différente et qui pourtant
pendant les premières années ont essayé
de s'accrocher et de soutenir le
gouvernement et il y en a aujourd'hui un
petit clan gouvernementale qui persiste
sur une ligne qui est rejeté par parler
maintenant un clan oui un clan
gouvernementale autour de françois
hollande avec quelques ministres et kiki
qui sont restés dans le soutien au tour
de manuel valls
mais les forces vives sociale et les
forces vives de la gohelle à gauche sont
ailleurs maîtrisait mal le gouvernement
nous ne sommes plus gouvernée par la
gauche nous sommes gouvernés
voilà une petite équipe autour de
hollande et de valls qui mène une
politique à droite et kiwis et qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec les électeurs de
gauche qui avait porté ce pouvoir alors
le débat est quand même ouvert a dit le
premier ministre et son texte
il a dit que le texte allait être
débattue il ya sur le parlement va jouer
son rôle
et si le gouvernement il va s'en occuper
et que le parlement puisse jouer ce rôle
parce que évidemment tout le monde est
revenu en arrière très vite sur l'idée
du 49-3 mais la simple idée que ça ait
pu traverser la tête de la ministre en
charge du texte de parler de ça avant
même qu'on connaisse le contenu tech
montre qu en dit long sur la confiance
quand même qu'ils ont dans les
parlementaires de leur maman y'a pas de
majorité je leur propre part vous êtes
convaincus vous aussi qui a pas de
majorité
peut-être sur ce texte aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucune majorité doublage sur ce
tales il ya interdit ici elle 49 points
l'ascenseur il est analyste et s'il est
adopté ce texte il est
ça veut dire qu'il sera adopté avec des
doigts de droite c'est d'ores et déjà
sur ça et si le gouvernement fait appel
aux 49 3 qu'est ce que vous faites vous
comme une et bien moi je proposerai à
l'ensemble des parlementaires de gauche
effectivement nouveauté une censure vous
votre et la sensuelle jeudi je
proposerai puisque nous n'avons pas les
moyens ou wei de déposer une motion soit
il vient d'ailleurs sommes pas
suffisamment
donc je proposerai à des parlementaires
à ce moment-là de gauche de gauche qui
ce qui serait opposé à cela de déposer
en ce moment une censure
comment est ce que vous comprenez le
pari d'une certaine manière de françois
hollande peut-il être espérer être réélu
en 2017 s'il se coupent de la gauche si
on suit votre démonstration mais je l'en
mais je pense que et je crois que nous
allons en parler par la suite je pense
que justement il ne peut pas être le
représentant de la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle il est difficile en étant
des et s'il prétend des lettres eh bien
il risquerait de conduire la gauche à un
échec majeur
will remain pas il ne doit pas se
représenter moi je crois qu'il ne doit
pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle au nom de la gauche il ne
peut pas l'être
on se retrouvera dans une situation
indigne adrien celui qui prétend
représenter la gauche devrait porter
pendant toute la campagne
la déchéance de nationalité le
dynamitage du code du travail
enfin c'est ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
compréhensible pour pour personne pour
personne de ceux qui ont voulu porter la
gauche voulait ramener à un rôle de
candidate figuration il à faire des
choix politiques tous pendant tout le
quinquennat alors on voit les cv
disqualifie la fed et il a fait des
choix politiques qui ont été
progressivement et de plus en plus
fortement à l'encontre de ce qui était
attendu
bien il n'a obtenu ni résultats en
matière de lutte contre le chômage ni
progrès social il n'a pas fait avancer
ski ski ski et les skis sont les grands
principes d'égalité pour le pays il n'a
pas porté là fortement la voix de la
france en europe pour faire évoluer
faire s'il est disqualifié sur tous les
terrains anc
je pense je l' ai déjà dit de très
nombreuses fois il est effectivement
disqualifié et il va et il pourrait si
on le laisse si on laissait faire nous
conduire à l'élimination pure et simple
de la gauche au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est à dire
on risque de se retrouver dans un
scénario qui est celui que nous venons
de vivre dans plusieurs grandes régions
françaises
jean luc mélenchon vous demande de
cesser de jouer de revenir à la raison
alors le divorce est consommé
la question du divorce comme vous dites
ou pas entre jean-luc mélenchon - n'est
absolument pas la question il y à une
discussion sérieuse à avoir et que nous
avons effectivement nous n'avons pas le
même avis sur cette question c'est que
les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
la politique gouvernementale
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas seulement
front de gauche avec jean-luc mélenchon
et moi même sont ils sont dans toute la
gauche
ils sont chez les écologistes et ils
sont dans une part grandissante du parti
socialiste
est ce que nous essayons de construire
ensemble une candide un projet et une
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
pour éviter l'élimination de la gauche
est ce que nous essayons de faire ça moi
je dis que il faut tout faire pour
essayer cela voilà et que 1 pour le
faire la meilleure manière de commencer
c'est pas que le front gauche déclare sa
candidature et dire à tout le monde vous
vous ralliez à notre affaire est-ce que
la cré front de gauche qui déclare sa
candidature c'est jean luc mélenchon une
candidature du front de gauche puisque
lui il a été le candidat du front de
gauche avec jean-luc mélenchon peut pas
dire qu'il part avec le parti communiste
non mais c'est la règle a nice c'est
certain que cette déclaration de
candidature s'est faite sans sans
consultation sans consultation du à vous
une partie au parti communiste
nous l'avons dit pas ou pas du tout pour
pauline polémiquer ou pour tirer des
balles l'argent que mélenchon c'est des
mots qui sont totalement excessif
mais tout simplement pour que chacun le
sache parce que ça fait partie de la
réalité et du débat politique
je répète la question c'est ce n'est pas
celle là la question et c'est une
question que moi j'adresse aussi à jean
luc mélenchon en lui disant il est
possible de revenir dans ensemble dans
ce travail collectif c'est une question
que je partage avec d'autres offrants
gauche parce que le parti communiste
n'est pas le seul à avoir des
interrogations sur cette candidature en
solo de jean luc mélenchon dont le front
gauche et ensemble nous essayons de dire
essayons plutôt de lancer des
passerelles jean luc mélenchon dit
chose curieuse il dit il dit dans
l'appel de ceux qui ont lancé un appel à
la primaire il y à 38 personnes qui
avaient voté françois hollande au
premier tour mais précisément c'est
quelle est la situation c'est que
l'immense masse de ceux qui ont voté
françois hollande au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle on vide un
autre choix
alors est ce que nous nous essayons avec
ces forces là de construire une
candidature ou pas si nous ne faisons
que jean luc mélenchon pourrait revenir
dans un processus collectif renoncé à se
présenter ce que s'ils se lève voir ses
pensées soleil met la pression sur lui
s'est sérieusement je pense que s'ils se
lève une dynamique citoyenne autour de
cette affaire ce qui n'est pas gagné
parce que évidemment si on présente le
débat que nous avons comme comme vous le
faites un peu la commune histoire de de
tambouille politicienne c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va intéresser les gens et ça
les gens n'ont absolument pas envie de
ça et ils ont mille fois raison moi ce
que je veux et c'est ce que j'ai proposé
d'ailleurs à ceux qui veulent une
primaire c'est que la première chose que
nous fassions cela n'est pas nous mettre
d'accord sur une liste de candidats
c'est qu'on organise dans tout le pays
pas deux trois débats des centaines des
milliers de déballer plus le plus proche
possible et qu'on invite tous les
citoyens à discuter de la situation dans
laquelle on est comment est ce qu'on va
sortir de cette situation et éviter le
piège d'une élection présidentielle on
va nous dire vous avez le choix entre la
droite le front national et une
candidature qui est celle du président
de la république sortant
jean christophe cambadélis parle de
stratégie de mesquinerie et de bisbille
entre partis c'est ça la primaire je
pense que jean christophe cambadélis
n'est pas du tout le ton qui l'emploie
là un peu un peu comme ça arrogant voilà
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de la
situation
la situation est grave dans le pays
elle est grave pour les gens elle est
grave parce que le gouvernement que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire monsieur
cambadélis soutien mais sur la table un
projet très inquiétant sur le code du
travail
donc jean christophe cambadélis devrait
se poser ces questions l'armée et voir
comment ils y répondent ça l'a plutôt
que d'essayer de jouer comme ça celui
qui donne des leçons ni l'exécutif ni le
chef du ps qui est quand même qui reste
le principal parti de gauche ne sont
vraiment d'accord comme vous dites
alors comment est ce que vous faites pas
organiser c'est une contradiction qui
existe dans le parti socialiste et que
moi je ne devais pas tranché à leur
place ce que je constate et c'est pour
ça que je crois ou un processus de
primaires c'est que de très très
nombreux socialistes et ça a commencé
par tout ce qu'on appelle la gauche du
ps qui a adopté une motion à l'unanimité
fin janvier alors que jean-christophe
cambadélis refusé de se prononcer pour
ce processus peut on dit banco parce
qu'il faut ré ouvrir le débat
donc moi ce que je constate c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est que de plus en plus de
socialiste est encore plus d'électeurs
socialistes de 2012 ont envie de ce
grand changement
ils n'ont pas envie de retourner avec un
candidat qui a trahi toutes ses
promesses à l'élection de 2012
alors est ce qu est ce qu on donne de
l'espace à ce débat là est ce qu'on crée
un cadre qui va permettre à tous ces
gens de dire voilà nous les priorités
que nous voulons parce que c'est aux
électeurs de définir le mandat pao pao
candidats nous sommes quand nous
présentons à des élections nous devons
rendre compte devant des électeurs
moi je dis à tous les électeurs de
gauche qui sont dégoûtés de la situation
actuelle c'est à vous de reprendre les
affaires au mans c'est à vous de vous
mêler de ce processus c'est à vous de
dire voilà quel doit être le monde
la du futur candidat qu'on aura et le
candidat on trouvera s'il ya des
candidats qui n'ont pas envie de ce
mandat là eh bien ils vont faire autre
chose mais ils n'ont pas en avant mais
justement martine aubry demain doit
participer enfin est donné participant
en tout cas une réunion des
organisateurs de cette primaire à gauche
est ce que par exemple martine aubry ce
serait quelqu'un derrière le mais je ne
parlerai pas qu'est-ce-qui mais sans
casting avec martine aubry ses idées est
ce que vous pourriez ce que ça pourrait
correspondre
mais il y a beaucoup de choses qu'il
faudrait je discute avec martine aubry
parce qu'on n'a pas eu les mêmes
positions ces derniers temps mais
s'était dit dans quelle qu'elle fait
partie elle déjà dit plusieurs fois de
ceux qui n'ont pas partagé les choix
gouvernementaux dans la dernière dans la
dernière période tout en ayant fait des
compromis qui n'ont pas très bien marché
quand même au dernier congrès du parti
socialiste mais je le répète avant
d'être bon on aura le temps de régler le
problème de la candidature avant cela il
faut d'abord créer ces conditions là
je pense que face au drame qui celui de
la guerre dans tout le grand moyen
orient nous dans lesquels nos propres
forces militaires sont engagés et qui
contribue à la fuite de gens qui sont
massacrés par la guerre et qui fuient
ces conflits et donc qu'ils ont droit à
l'asile
eh bien je pense que l'europe devrait se
mobiliser tout en termes et mais c'est
un problème qui devrait être
effectivement traitée dans la solidarité
au plan européen est ce que vous êtes il
ya l'accueil des migrants qui le
souhaitent qu'ils soient de venir en
france est ce que vous seriez pour je
pense qu'il faut faire plusieurs choses
il faut en tout cas on accueillir
beaucoup de kilomètres simone beaucoup
plus bien sûr
aujourd'hui ça serait 30000 vous
souhaitez que se sont beaucoup plus la
france c'est un chiffre ridicule
ridicule pour la france et un chiffre
indigne même par rapport à ce qui se
passe il y a des 110 km à l'est durement
venir d'un autre pays
non mais ça c'est une autre question
personne ne dit qu'on va obliger les
migrants à aller dans tel ou tel pays
mais nous sommes dans une situation qui
est grave et qui équilibrent crise'
total par exemple nous disons nous
disons aux grecs au gouvernement grec et
alexis tsipras sa protester contre cette
attitude au dernier sommet européen
on dit aux grecs vous êtes la frontière
de l'europe c'est à vous de faire la
police dans votre seul pays sur les îles
grecques etc et débrouillez vous avec le
problème
et puis à l'intérieur de l'europe pour
ferme toutes les frontières et quand des
réfugiés traverse la grèce
il y à des pays qui sont juste au nord
de la grèce qui ferment leurs frontières
à personne ni rien alex
et vous avez dit récemment que il faut
forcer votre nature quand on veut
devenir un personnage public et
médiatique
c'est par devoir que vous le faites pas
rose non mais c'est moi j'aime beaucoup
ce que je fais j'adore j'adore la
politique et j'adore la politique de
proximité et ce que j'ai dit dans
l'interview auquel vous faites allusion
dans les bars additionnel je n'aime pas
je n'aime pas le pouvoir personnel et je
mens messi et je trouve que pour un
communiste est d'ailleurs d'une manière
générale pour quelqu'un qui fait de la
politique c'est plutôt une qualité de se
méfier du pouvoir personnel
alors c'est vrai que nous vivons dans
une vie politique et médiatique qui
personnalise tout est de ce point de vue
je dis oui je force ma nature parce que
moi je crois davantage et encore avoir
de la mare davantage ou collectifs au
travail collectif que à la mise en scène
personnelle et je pense que s'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans notre
vie démocratique c'est précisément ça
parce qu'une des choses il pourrit la
vie politique française oui c'est la
mise en scène présidentielle permanente
n'a par exemple jamais les quads et la
route d'albi police appelle un metteur
en scène polonais est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez qu'elle vous
pourriez songé mais quand vous êtes
effectivement quand vous êtes obligés de
vous mettre en scène et que vous êtes
présents eh ben vous faites conseiller
c'est tout c'est vous le fait mal vous
le faites rationnement mais moi aussi je
conseille de ce type
parce que il faut il faire apprendre à
parler réémetteurs c'est dans les médias
il faut faire des choses comme ça et je
n'ai pas du tout on de ça ça n'est pas
le problème mais en même temps que je
fais ça et je ne suis déjà plus même par
rapport à ce que j' étais quand je suis
devenu secrétaire national du parti
communiste et je ne vais cesser de
m'améliorer je vous rassure quoi b mais
en même temps qu'ils que je fais ça
c'est vrai que moi j'alerte les les
citoyens auxquels je m'adresse vos
téléspectateurs et je le redis je le
redis ne vous laissez pas abuser par
toutes ces mises en scène par ce que
croyait davantage en votre force
collective et croyait davantage on la
sincérité et en la proximité de travail
des hommes politiques quand leur mise en
scène médias
sic